hey guys it's justine and today we are
in the kitchen and we are cooking
something with this oven right here not
this one
this one this is the brava oven and i've
made a video about this before and i've
talked about it so many times on my
instagram and twitter
i love this thing and i'm not a huge fan
of cooking but this thing makes cooking
super simple and it also cooks with
infrared light so it cooks very quickly
efficiently and it has all of these
recipes
and you can connect it to your phone
there's a camera in it i can watch my
food cook
i find my recipes on my phone i make
them and i put them in the oven i push
the button and that's
basically it my meal is cooked but today
we're going to be making
one of my custom cooks they have this
option in here where you're able to take
some recipes that brava already has in
their system you can make various custom
cooks so basically you can become a chef
you can share your recipes with the
bravo community and today i'm going to
make you one of my favorite breakfast
meals so i just made my own custom cook
there's so many different options of
things you can do they have a whole list
here so you can search for your food
buy the photos or you can click search
and you can basically search for
anything that you want to make but today
we are going to be doing the custom cook
but i've already made mine this is
ijustine's breakfast bowl
this tells you that we need the metal
tray we're gonna be keeping it on the
top let's do it
first step we need our frozen breakfast
sausage frozen sausage where are you
in the freezer it's where it is do we
want chicken and sage
or do we want savory turkey i have a
problem i
really really like frozen
like there's nothing that i hate more
when i go into the freezer and i don't
have my frozen sausage i think that i'm
just gonna do the savory turkey because
this doesn't have any added flavors or
anything it's just you know kind of
basic because we're going to add our own
flavoring
[Applause]
so i would say depending upon how many
people you're making this for i'm making
four servings but four servings i feel
like is actually for two people
so that's just my appetite
custom cook ready to go see you soon
there's my little sausages they're oh my
gosh look you can see them
i wonder if i can do an hdmi out and do
a live stream of this
so while the sausages are cooking i'm
gonna start working on my breakfast
potatoes so for those
i'm gonna be just using the brava recipe
so i'm gonna need potatoes
some onions and a pepper it said a red
pepper but i couldn't get
a red pepper in two hours on the
internet to be delivered immediately so
we're gonna do a green pepper
the recipe called for paprika i've never
used this in my life but today
we are what are you am i gonna like this
do you think
oh oh look the best part about all of
this is i can see
my meat cooking look those are our
sausages
they're being cooked
[Music]
that looks nice i was on chopped once
don't you forget it
when they asked if i had my own knives i
was like wait you guys don't have any
like well a lot of our chefs you know
they have like their special knives i
was like i don't mind from the internet
you think i've got special knives i
don't now we're gonna slice up our onion
more or less to taste looking good
before we started tyler was teaching me
to cut an onion
so we'll see if i will make him proud or
not or if he's cringing behind camera
he's cringing doing it we're
slicing and dicing that's a lot we don't
need that much
you guys are getting a real treat today
because normally i use frozen potatoes
who's ready for some home fries now this
is gonna be my third breakfast today i
just want it to be known
it's really it's stuck on there really
just
very sticky but now that word's gonna be
stuck in my head
sticking this out just to keep it
we have got sticky potatoes all up in
this joint
oh yes our sausages okay so i'm gonna
chop up these sausages while the
potatoes are cooking
and then i'm gonna put the sausages back
in when we do the eggs
the one thing that is nice is this top
of the oven is actually heat resistant
so you can put hot pans on it let's toss
these in some olive oil and some salt
and a paprika
do you like onions okay
i think we'll do all the peppers though
because those are nice
is that too much these are some sea salt
flakes
you don't even know about that usually
my frozen version
it's already seasoned and everything but
this is this is the way to do it
our pan is fully covered with our
potatoes and peppers and onions and now
we're gonna roast these up
as step two and you go
let's do it our breakfast potatoes are
cooking up i was trying to find a
smaller cutting board but this was the
smallest that i could find
sticky patello getting those potatoes
not so sticky
i'm gonna wash my potatoes while i cut
the sausage also
i have an herb garden so i'm gonna put
some fresh herbs in this
oh boy the last step is here
can we just look at this this is going
to be fun because now i'm going to make
little
nests here and i'm going to put the eggs
in and they're just going to kind of
like do their thing and they're going to
get all fried up we're going to have a
delicious breakfast
i'm calling these a little egg nest with
the sausages back on
so back in the oven we go
for our final cook
[Music]
i should start getting my fresh herbs
ready
[Music]
oh my harvest that smells so good these
look done i'm just gonna let it stay
warm
jenna's here something
smells delightful uh yes my fresh
harvest look at this
good fresh the big reveal the big reveal
is here
oh can you just take a look at
that tyler is salivating over there
those potatoes
yes our masterpiece guys i'm taking my
photo
for the recipe that looks
absolutely incredible
can you just i just want to say i'm so
happy with my
with my performance you want one serving
you want two servings
[Music]
a little bit of salt we have
made food so here's my finished
breakfast bowl i'm so excited to eat
this but one of the things that i love
so much about these recipes is if you
want to swap something out so if you
want to use bacon instead of sausage or
if you want to use some sort of meat
substitute that is also okay as well
i'll put a link in the description if
you want to learn more about the bravo
oven and everything else that it has to
offer and it's constantly being updated
tyler would you like the big boy two
servings okay that sounds good
[Music]
oh look at that oh man
potatoes sausage in your egg look what
is better
nothing and my fresh herbs i'm sorry
jenna i didn't make a meatless version
for you
okay this is so good
gonna go eat in private